hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast psychosis as a learning memory
disorder I am Brenda Kelly Kim of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
presentation has been approved for
category 1 continuing medical education
credit by loma linda university if you
are interested in obtaining cme's after
attending this presentation please click
on the get your free cme c ii credits
button in the bottom left corner of the
event screen this webcast is designed to
be interactive and we encourage you to
ask questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker dr. Carol
tenango dr. Kananga is the professor and
chairman in the department of psychiatry
at UT Southwestern Medical School she
has spent her career studying biomarkers
and mechanisms of psychosis in
schizophrenia and psychosis treatment
using translational approaches she has
contributed to an understanding of the
role of hippocampus in psychosis the
area she will talk about today dr.
Kananga is currently a member of ni-mh
National Advisory Board deputy editor of
the american journal of psychiatry and
on the editorial board of several other
journals dr. tan manga was elected to
the Institute of Medicine of the
National Academies of Sciences in 1998 I
will now turn it over tada
to Canada for her presentation well
thank you I'm delighted to be with you
today I'm delighted to talk about
psychosis as a learning and memory
disorder psychosis is an unusual kind of
mental phenomenon that has a bizarre and
difficult to understand manifestation so
my current work is really contributed to
an understanding of psychosis being a
brain disease much like other learning
and memory disorders are let me tell you
what I'm going to talk about today and
I'm going to talk about under the
overall on subject area of tracking
psychosis and schizophrenia so
schizophrenia is the most chronic and
the most enduring of the psychosis so
what I'm going to say about psych psycho
psychotic disease is in general I'll use
schizophrenia as an example of I'll tell
you what schizophrenia is what part of
the brain is affected in schizophrenia
hopefully something about what's
affected in the area that I've selected
and how the pathology that we found in
that area actually generates psychosis
now this is all for the goal of really
finding new targets to treat a new ways
to treat psychosis so I'll tell you what
my thoughts are although that's really
the least developed of these areas
psychosis or schizophrenia is a disease
for which our understanding has evolved
over the centuries schizophrenia or
psychosis is a condition that's been
with us since the dawn of civilization
what you see in the picture on the left
is it is what's depicted from a mental
hospital in london called bethlehem
hospital in 1750 it's an engraving now
if a British person says Bethlehem very
quickly it will sound like the word
bedlam and bedlam actually came into the
English language to describe scenes like
this and the right of the picture
is another illustration of psychosis
really and this came from the National
Geographic the National Geographic had a
the National Geographic had a of story
in nineteen nineteen ninety-six about
schizophrenia as a disease of the brain
and it was really one of the first
stories and the public US media where
schizophrenia was identified as a brain
disease so how do we understand what is
the experience of psychosis what's the
experience of schizophrenia John Nash
won the Nobel Prize for economics in
1994 and he had the DS had the disease
of schizophrenia since he's been 31
years old dr. Nash is a brilliant man
he's a mathematician he made discoveries
on game theory that have revolutionized
of the practice of economics nonetheless
John Nash is psychotic and he describes
his psychotic ideas here he believes
he's a the left foot of God walking on
the earth um one time um he dr. Nash's
equally brilliant on Princeton
colleagues mathematician colleagues came
to see him in the hospital and said John
how can you think stuff like this and
his response was very telling he said
these ideas come into my head just like
all of my other ideas do I have no
choice but to believe them those there's
another very famous first person who
wrote a first-person account of
schizophrenia a person with the illness
called whose name is Alan sack she wrote
the book the center cannot hold and she
describes here what one of her psychotic
like experiences is sights and sounds
and thoughts and feelings don't go
together there's no organizing principle
which takes successive moments in time
and puts them in together into a
coherent way from which sense can be
made dr. Sachs had the onset of her
illness when she was on a Fulbright
sabbatical in England she was treated
acutely she got her got herself together
before she came back to the United
States and she had this uh.this
prescient thought and she said to
herself you know fact if I tell people I
have to get their friendly I'll never
get a good job so she came back to the
United States did not tell people she
had schizophrenia went to law school
graduated at the top of her class went
on to practice and academic law at USC
she was an assistant professor she was
associate professor and then she became
a full professor with tenure and just as
soon as she got her tenure she wrote
this book the center cannot hold it's a
very exciting book dr. saxes picture is
right in the middle of this collage of
pictures here John Nash's to the left
during his Nobel Prize ceremony both dr.
Nash and dr. Sachs have hallucinations
and delusions which are tolerable the
people pictured on to the on the right
side of this collage are the more
infamous people with schizophrenia and
they have really different kinds of
hallucinations that are that are
aggressive and threatening so skip funny
has certain characteristics that all of
you undoubtedly know very well it has
about a one between one and two percent
prevalence although you would think that
this prevalence is fairly low site the
psychosis begins so early at 18 to 20 to
26 years and it lasts a lifetime so it's
a it's a lifetime long disease often
times cognitive dysfunction precedes the
onset of psychosis itself and I'm going
to really tell you more about those
symptoms subsets and schizophrenia in
just a minute what's most difficult
about schizophrenia and what's really
what drives people the most to treat it
is that there's really a profound
psychosocial dysfunction only less than
fifteen percent of people with
schizophrenia are ever employed less
than twenty percent ever marry and less
than five percent ever recover if you
call recovery
to be rid of all of the psychotic
symptoms it's a very expensive disease
there's a lot of personal and family
costs to the disease and so far the
pathophysiology is not known even though
the pathophysiology is not known one of
the things that gives all of us hope and
enthusiasm is the very rapid growth
growth in basic neuroscience it's a very
it's a very fast growth of what we know
about the brain in particular and that's
really given giving us new ideas about
new ways to understand and new
treatments so in nineteen this is a very
old set of data to published in 1974 as
you can see in 1974 the World Health
Organization asked a question to
schizophrenia look the same around the
world and it sent a team of
investigators to seven different
countries both developed countries and
undeveloped countries and they raided
symptoms and they talked to the people
with schizophrenia and sure enough the
answer was yes pizza friend Ian does
look the same around the world one of
the most prominent symptoms of
schizophrenia is the one that's listed
on the top of this list of the list loss
of insight and it's it's valium really a
ubiquitous symptom in the whole illness
and what this means actually is that a
person with schizophrenia cannot tell
the difference between what's reality
and what their and their and their
symptom picture they it really does seem
to them like people are talking to them
it's not it's not a host nation it's not
an unreal experience so some of the
people with the illness say that the
most difficult part is not knowing
whether what they're experiencing is a
symptom or is really happening there are
certain risk factors for schizophrenia
all of you seen these before genetics is
a risk factor prenatal events perinatal
accidents early environmental factors
and winter birth it's especially these
prenatal perinatal and early environment
risk
actors for schizophrenia then I'll call
your attention to although these factors
are not as predominant as genetics they
they include things like early early by
early i mean sometimes below the age of
five neglect and trauma before the age
of five illness particularly infectious
illness and famine during the during the
time of brain formation in utero on
these these all afford a small but
measurable risk to people with
schizophrenia who later on get
schizophrenia the genetic risk is
something that we know more precisely
where there's a one-percent prevalence
in the general population as one's
relationship to a person with
schizophrenia gets closer and closer the
genetic risk for schizophrenia increases
but you'll you'll see that really for
monozygotic twins which have the
greatest genetic risk so if you have a
monozygotic twin with schizophrenia
you'll have a forty to fifty percent
chance of i'm getting the illness this
really means that there's a lot of
schizophrenia that's determined by non
genetic causes so i said earlier that
schizophrenia phenomenology when you
look at people with schizophrenia you'll
see many different kinds of symptom
manifestations and over the last 20
years we've taken to dividing to
clustering these symptomatic eight
manifestations into different groups and
really looking for the pathophysiology
looking for the central nervous system
mechanisms differently for each of the
dysfunctions we don't know for sure that
they're different but but it's a it
makes them and we don't really know how
precisely to divide them up but most
people really divide schizophrenia
phenomenology or schizophrenia
manifestations into things like
psychosis into cognitive dysfunction
into mood dysfunction into negative
symptoms and what I'm going to be
talking about today is really the
psychotic set
of schizophrenia phenomenology
hallucinations delusions thought
disorder so for somebody who has
psychosis and schizophrenia this
psychotic cluster of symptoms which part
of the brain is affected now people have
really tried to answer this question in
many different ways so I'm showing you
the results of one study where the
people looked at a resting state fMRI
you can look at you can answer this
question and people have looked tried to
answer this question with many different
kinds of imaging modalities different
kinds of EEG abnormalities what you'll
notice there are six different pictures
here and you'll notice on the brain
these regions that are indicated in blue
and in the regions that are indicated in
blue are regions where people with
schizophrenia have a reduced neural
activity in these regions when they're
in the scanner if you look on the bottom
the very bottom sections here that I
circled on the left and on the right I
circled with a red circle these are the
areas where activity is increased in
schizophrenia and these are the
parahippocampal gyrus right where the
hippocampus is located so what this
suggests to us is that in the neocortex
and in some of the subcortical
structures like the thalamus and like
the cerebellum regional brain function
is decreased in schizophrenia but there
is one region one region on the right in
one region on the left and that is a
hippocampus or regional brain function
is increased now that's what kind of an
unusual it's unusual contrast to all the
rest schizophrenia is clearly a whole
brain disease but it also always has
been fascinating to me that it was the
hippocampus which which had a different
direction and valence if you will for a
basal and neural activity here's what
the human hippocampus looks like in in
real life actually this is this comes
from a cadaver brain on the left side of
the structure that you see there is the
anterior part of the hippocampus and you
can see it's a little the structures a
little wavy and that's the head of thing
at the campus and then if you look at
the opposite end that's the what's
called the tail of the hippocampus now
this the hippocampus on your left and
your right is about the size of your
small finger so hippocampus is not very
big relatively speaking the hippocampus
is much smaller in the human brain than
it is in other brains am I am I still do
it if this is still going on okay excuse
me I'll just keep on and but the
hippocampus really all the way from
small animals to humans has been
implicated in memory production and I'll
tell you a little bit about that what
does the hippocampus do for memory so
when sensory when sensory information
comes into the brain it comes into a
primary sensory cortex both visual
cortex auditory cortex where the
sensorimotor the sensorimotor cortex
itself encodes the exact characteristics
of the stimuli then it sends those exact
characteristics of the stimuli up to the
parahippocampal region and those
individuals stimuli are fit together to
make their own picture and finally the
pairs of the Capital Region sends the
whole set of stimulii to the hippocampus
and you'll see in the bottom picture
that the hippocampus finally puts the
whole memory together into a context so
what they hypocrites individual encoded
sensory experiences and it puts them
into together into a whole memory and
then it sends this whole memory on out
to the neocortex for storage so if
I were giving a lecture and memory today
and they had to answer the question what
is episodic memory episodic memory the
term really means long-term memory for
general facts and specific events it
includes both the encoding or the making
of the memory and the retrieval of the
memory or getting the getting the memory
back out of neocortex and it's important
to remember that memory is done
independent of consciousness you don't
have to sit all day and look at
something and think to yourself I need
to make a memory of that but your brain
does this automatically the hippocampus
is plays a role in memory in the role
that it plays is binding the distinct
elements of an event into memory such
that it captures the relationships
between those events so memory
flexibility or pneumonic flexibility is
people say allows for the novel use of
stored knowledge consciously or
unconsciously and what that really means
is that every time you pull up a memory
that memory becomes available for
editing essentially so and then you can
put the edited memory back in storage
now the reason that we know so much
about memory is from hm for many years I
just knew hm by those two initials hm
passed away some number of years of oh
so now that we know that his name is
Henry Malaya San Henry R Elias and it
was is is a man who when he was 26 year
old 26 years old had intractable
epilepsy just at the time that
neurosurgeons understood that if they
took out the epileptic foci they could
sometimes cure intractable epilepsy HM
had the unlucky situation of having a
having an epileptic focus identified in
his right and his left hippocampus so
without thinking about it really without
any reason to think differently the
neurosurgeons went in and
out of his right and his left
hippocampus and surely enough the
operation took care of his epilepsy and
HM no longer had any more had no seizure
disorder but from that time on he could
not make any more new episodic memories
he could remember memories that he had
when he was a child he could make his
way around his childhood neighborhood
but you couldn't learn a new
neighborhood and couldn't learn the
streets around his new house so what did
HM teach us about memory first of all
that memory is a distinct psychological
function amnesia which is what he had is
an impairment of episodic memory amnesia
spares short-term memory and working
memory because sure it surely enough hm
had short-term memory and yet working
memory hm really taught us that the
hippocampus is the core brain structure
supporting declarative memory and that
the hippocampus supports the permanent
consolidation of memories so just about
normal memory I'll get back to
schizophrenia in a minute but just about
normal memory there's a well-known
anatomy of memory in the hippocampus so
the hippocampus really the brain region
that leads right into the hippocampus is
the in Toronto cortex you could think of
the n-terminal cortex as a as a vortex
shaped structure which takes information
from over the from from the whole
neocortex from primary sensory cortex
cortices as well as from associational
courts cortices and it takes all the
information all together and it it it
pulls it in and it pulls it down to a to
a memory to a stream of sensory input
that it's going to send through the
hippocampus the main route to the kippah
campus is called the tri synaptic
pathway going from the in toronto cortex
to the dentate gyrus to see a 3 c a1 and
civic ulam there are a few direct
connections between the in toronto
cortex in each one of those but the main
pathway
is called the try synaptic pathways each
one of these stops each one of the
stations in the tri synaptic pathway has
its own distinct memory function the
dentate gyrus is full of recurrent
collaterals on but but it's thought to
have the function of pattern separation
and when all of these ideas come into
when all of these sensory inputs come
into the hippocampus the hippocampus has
to automatically decide what's the new
memory and what it already has made a
memory of so it can just retrieve it
from storage so the dentate gyrus
participates a lot in separating out
whether something is a new memory are an
old memory then them then the memory
information goes on to see a three which
is an auto associational area where a
pattern completion occurs and there's
rich collateral pathways of collateral
connection cell to cell connections
within CA three then the whole memory
construct after it's been worked on by
the dent hrs NC three goes onto ca-1 and
a lot of editing and streamlining goes
on in CA 1 and in civic ulam and by the
time a memory comes through all these
stations there's a memory that goes out
of out of the Civic ulam and then back
up to the neocortex for for storage now
there's a synaptic basis of memory which
is really synaptic plasticity there's a
deluxe picture you can see the electron
microscopy picture of a human synapse
and some of the molecular entities that
you see in the illustration on the right
are really keyed in by those black
circles on the Left that's psd-95 now
within the synapse the of course the
presynaptic area is very active because
that's the area from which glutamate is
release glutamate and gaba in these
synaptic plasticity phenomena and the
postsynaptic membrane is made up of a
constantly changing array of
glutamatergic and other kinds of
receptors and then a very very complex
intracellular signaling system that are
that that are responsive to this the
different kinds of receptors on the
postsynaptic membrane and this is really
the synaptic basis are thought to be the
synaptic basis of memory now I've told
you a little bit about episodic memory
and hippocampal function in the normal
human the normal mammalian brain what's
what really happens in schizophrenia
what's uh what's abnormal about any of
this in schizophrenia and the message
that I've used to answer this question
our both human post-mortem brain and
human brain imaging and I'll tell you a
little bit about both in order to answer
the question what is affected in
hippocampus in schizophrenia first of
all we know that memory performance is
abnormal and schizophrenia on memory
performance is abnormal and a lot of
different kinds of brain diseases and
brain diseases like Alzheimer's disease
memory performance is decreased but it's
a decrease uniformly and it's decreased
in all aspects of memory performance in
schizophrenia the situation is different
in schizophrenia there are some
functions of memory that are
particularly impaired and there are some
functions of memory that are perfectly
normal if you look at the picture on the
left hand side of the if you the image
on the the grass on the left hand side
of the slide it's this is a task called
the acquired equivalence performance
task and if you look at that first task
which it says trained underneath there
we gave both normal people and people
with schizophrenia schizophrenias people
with schizophrenia both off medicine and
on medicine we we taught them a task and
then we asked them to we just assess
whether they have learned the task
and sure enough people with
schizophrenia can could learn the task
just as well as normal people and when
we asked them what the answer was that
they had already learned they were able
to pull it up and give us the right
answer when we asked them another kind
of memory task really we asked them to
pull something to retrieve something
from their memory and we asked them then
to do a logical do a logical task with
that information that was where the
people with schizophrenia really could
not do the task at all people off
medication in the middle bar performed
almost at the level of chance almost at
the level of fifty percent and people
who were on medicine had a slightly
better performance but they were still
significantly worse than the normal
people in the next slide you'll see
another kind of memory the next the
picture on the right under pattern
separation performance you'll see
another kind of function at which people
with schizophrenia do poorly one kind of
function that we tested which is called
recognition their recognition memory was
not different between people with
schizophrenia and people not but the
pattern separation component of the
memory the ability of a person with with
schizophrenia to see subtle differences
in objects and note that it was a new
memory that kind of patter separation
activity was almost non-existent in
people with schizophrenia so that was
just an example of how people what are
what kind of cognition abnormalities
people with schizophrenia have there is
a small here's just a kind of a list of
things you can find in the literature of
hippocampal alterations that have been
reported in schizophrenia us the
hippocampal volume is consistently
reduced in schizophrenia this reduction
is very very small it's only four to
five four to five percent reduction but
it's so consistent and it's found in
almost every laboratory that's ever
looked at it so it must be meaningful in
some way we don't quite know what the
meaning of it is yet there's a knit
number two is an impairment in men
performance particularly relational
memory and pattern separation that's
just what I showed you there is an
increase in hippocampal basal perfusion
and I'll show you what that is in just a
minute and then there's an activation
deficit during declarative memory tasks
which is when you give to hippocampus a
pass to do the the neural activity is
lower in schizophrenia than in normal
even though if you look at the neural
activity at baseline the hippocampal
activity will be increased that was
really the first slide I showed you
probably 10 slides ago decreased
neurogenesis has been reported in the in
the dentate gyrus and adequately an
altered efferent excitatory signaling
from the dentate gyrus so we we find
increased neuronal activity and
hippocampus in schizophrenia let me show
you what we find and and I'll say right
from the beginning that this has been
found from a number of different
laboratories we've looked at neural
activity in hippocampus the hippocampus
is a you see the hippocampus there on
lateral view in a live person I showed
it to you before from a cadaver here you
see really what the mr image of a
hippocampus looks like and the yellow of
the yellow arrows show you the anterior
part of the hippocampus and the black
arrow will show you the posterior part
in a small animal like a rat or a mouse
the posterior part curls up to become
the dorsal hippocampus the ventral
hippocampus is equivalent in the in the
small animal is equivalent to the
anterior pocampus in the human because
the differences of course the density of
the neocortex and that just really
flattens the hippocampus right out now
the hippocampus particularly in its
anterior extent particularly where you
see those yellow areas the hippocampus
has an increase in profusion and that
increase in profusion can be seen with
pet and 0 15 water like to see on the
left and if you do another technique
which is a magnetic resonance technique
and look at the cerebral blood volume
you can see an increase in CA trees and
see a one in schizophrenia as well so
one of our early studies what you see on
the left is a histologic picture of the
hippocampus you can see the horseshoe
shaped dent hrs and coming out of the
dentate gyrus of ca3 and then behind on
the backside of the dentate gyrus of ca1
and then cibecue llam going is the
straight line going on algorithm campus
we've looked several different times at
at glutamate receptor subunits in the
different hippocampal subfield and what
we see in this in this data set here is
that it's only in the dentate gyrus but
in the dentate gyrus there's a reduction
in blue in one which is the critical
subunit of the NMDA receptor this there
is no decrease in ca3 and there is no
decrease in ca1 there's only a
significant decrease in the dentate
gyrus so we were trying to understand
how to fit together the idea that the
hippocampus that neural activity in the
hippocampus is hyperactive but when we
look at the obligate subunit of the NMDA
receptor in dentate gyrus we find a
decrease in not an increase how can it
be that this that there's a decrease in
on what we would interpret as
glutamatergic activity or glutamatergic
signaling in the dentate gyrus but
overall in the whole hippocampus there's
an increase in neuronal activity so we
finally made a model and this model that
you're seeing here when we first made it
was an entirely speculative model what
we what we speculated was that there was
a molecular lesion in the dentate gyrus
so that in the dentate gyrus that was
reduced glutamate signaling which would
account therefore for push poor pattern
separation which I've already showed you
is one of the cognitive consequences in
in cognitive characteristics in
schizophrenia we reason that this
decrease in glutamate signaling would
decrease the activity in the mossy fiber
pathway which is the pathway connecting
dentate gyrus with ca3 and that there
would be a decreased excitatory effort
signal in ca3 now one of the things that
happens in the glutamatergic system when
there's a decreased affair and signal is
that the on the glutamate system
responds with the hypersensitivity in
order to preserve the it becomes
hypersensitive in order to not miss the
incoming signals so that within CA three
there would be an increase in LTP
perhaps an increase in regional cerebral
blood flow an exaggeration in the
functions of ca3 which would be a
pattern complete completion and a hyper
associational activity and that this
increase in ca3 activity would be
transmitted downstream to see a one and
two civilian now this was a speculative
model but the reason we made them on was
to go on and see if we could find any if
we could really find um we could find
any evidence to support that so the
first thing we looked at were the
glutamate receptor subunits glutamate
receptor has its it's critical subunit
is blue and one and in ca3 glue and one
was exactly the same in normals and
schizophrenics we looked at glue into V
and we looked at two in glue and to be
containing NMDA receptors and we found
in schizophrenia which you can see in
the slide in front of you is that blew
into V containing NMDA receptors are
higher in schizophrenia and in then in
normal within CA three now we measured
the same measure in ca1 to see if this
same molecular lesion
also was present in either dentate gyrus
or ca1 and it's only present in ca3 it's
only present in ca3 and what you see on
the right is the schemes that I've
really taken from mark there and Rob
malenko's homeostatic meta plasticity
articles where they have shown that when
there's an increased or decreased affair
and stimulation the tissue that's
receiving the signal the affair and
signal adjusts itself to either decrease
its sensitivity or increase in
sensitivity and this written this piece
of data indicates increased synaptic
strength in ca3 so then we also looked
at another coat it's really a cold
protein the protein psd-95 and p.s mean
psd-95 generates the the protein matrix
that actually tethers in the NMDA in the
anthro receptors into the PO into the
synapse into the postsynaptic membrane
and this psd-95 was also increased so we
thought that that was really very
interesting and what we wanted to do
next these these would these two
measures are measures of increased
synaptic strength but really the
defining and the defining picture the
defining measure of increase in somatic
strength is to really look to see
whether or not we could show an increase
in dendritic spine number in people with
schizophrenia in tissue in tissue from
cases with schizophrenia so we looked at
human post-mortem tissue and we looked
at the ca3 region and you can see in the
box and that's labeled a you can see
these beautiful um ca3 pyramidal neurons
you can see why they're called parameter
ons because in fact they look like
pyramidal cell pyramidal shaped cells
and the apical dendrites of these prime
neurons are splayed upward in that
particular picture and then in the frame
that's called be you can see what the
effort what the mossy fiber pathway
synapses look like and this is
particularly what they look like in
schizophrenia then if you look at C and
D you can see the apical dendrites from
the normal controls and you can see the
apical dendrites on these pyramidal
neurons from people with schizophrenia
and you can see just just by eyeballing
that you can see that the pyramidal
neurons from people with schizophrenia
are blanketed with far more synapses
than they are in the in the normal in
the normal tissue now what you see in
ens is you see the another synaptic area
within ca3 the area of the insertion of
the recurrent collaterals and in this in
in these pieces of tissue a is normal
and f is the schizophrenics and you can
see in ens there's really the same
number of synapses there's no increase
so this is not an increase in sin x
number on the whole neuron but only on
the apical dendrites so what you can see
from everything that I've been telling
you if you look at the kind of a
different depiction of the tri synaptic
pathway from the in Toronto cortex to
the den page ours to see a 3 c a1 and
civic ulam you can see that there are
several different kinds of molecular and
cellular lesions throughout the
hippocampus but these are all subfield
specific and they do seem to fit the
pattern of a decrease in glutamatergic
activity in the dentate gyrus with then
a reactive supersensitivity in ca3 now
if there was just a simple increase in
sensitivity in ca3 you would expect that
sensitivity with in ca3 to adjust with
whatever the F Ferentz Tim you
pation was and we don't really see that
happening in people with schizophrenia
there seems to be no adjustment of this
hippocampal hyperactivity so there must
be lesions in addition to in addition to
the lesions that I'm showing you today
that we haven't found yet and we have
ways that we're looking for them so how
does this pathway even generate
psychosis what I've showed you already
is that there's increase to the temple
blood flow consistent with increased
neuronal activity within the hippocampus
there's an increase in there's evidence
for an increase in epic strength and ca3
and we would suggest that this is
influenced by the reduced glutamate
signal from dentate gyrus we show
increased spines and terminal insertions
and c3 consistent with increased
synaptic strength so basically what we
really think is that psychosis could be
associated with hippocampal
hyperactivity when this hippocampal
hyperactivity exceeds the capacity of
the organ to manage the the capacity for
normal memory what happens is that the
hippocampus generates false memories it
makes mistakes and some of these false
memories could have psychotic content
during and and this could be
particularly important during the active
psychosis of the person this is this is
just again an illustration of what I've
already said and what I've already
showed you this would be considered this
is these are really the databases for my
contention that schizophrenic psychosis
is a learning and memory disorder and
that its associated with the
establishment of false memories some of
those false memories with psychosis once
the hippocampus make some memory the
hippocampus doesn't does not distinguish
between a good memory and a bad memory
or a psychotic memory and then in a real
memory of this the hippocampus can't do
that so if you're a hippocampus
made a mistake and falsely created a
memory you would experience that just as
if it were an idea just like any of your
others which is how John Nash describes
his psychosis now we have ongoing
experiments to really carry this out a
little bit further and I can tell you
what some of these are we've done a
transcriptome analysis for novel
proteins in ca3 the protein analyses
that i showed you were hypothesized
proteins for sure we would we would
assume that there are proteins that are
involved in all this that we don't know
about but that will find out about when
we're doing a transcriptome analysis and
we've already got some results from a
very early analysis and we're in the
process of doing more we're developing
an animal model where we're going to try
to match the defect in and in an animal
model with what with a pathology that
hippocampal pathology that we see in
schizophrenia and and we're in the
process of doing that now if if you
think from all of this what we can how
we can move to the next step what does
this all indicate about how we can treat
psychosis there are several different
things that were that we could think
about doing first of all we could try to
affect the hippocampal hyperactivity
from the external part of the skull
using in our simulation methods so
recently direct current stimulation has
been one of the neuromodulatory
approaches and one could try to modify
hippocampal hyperactivity one of the
things about the hippocampus is that
it's so medial and it's so low in the
brain it's actually hard to to reach
there are some specific gluant going to
be specific antagonists I sempron or
would be one Pfizer has a has a an
antagonist 101 606 there are several
specific blue and to be NMDA antagonists
and development and recently for the
treatment of stroke actually there's
been a psd-95 and tagging
which is understudy for its application
and stroke and these would all be drugs
that we would have some interest in
testing in psychosis now the question
would be whether you could give a drug
like this to somebody with us with
psychotic symptoms that they had had for
20 years and whether you could expect
any response or perhaps whether you
could you should give drugs like this
during acute psychotic episodes when
psychosis is really an evolving
structure what is really evolving and
then you would really prevent the
development of psychosis so I did this
work with a lot of collaborators of mine
and you can see their names listed out
here I'm sure you guys don't know any of
these people but we've all worked
together over the years to do this with
that I think I'll stop my talk and look
at my telephone for or maybe my screen
for some questions you might have thank
you dr. Tanika for that interesting
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I'd like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can
our first question in memory performance
and hippocampal morphology what are the
differences between people who are
diagnosed with schizophrenia versus
those with frontotemporal dementia
depression PTSD and anxiety disorders
wow what a question is this this is a
very you know the question does suggest
it does it does indicate that all of us
know that the hippocampus is involved in
a lot of other disorders so how is the
hippocampus distinct from the of these
other disorders in neurodegenerative
disorders and in frontotemporal dementia
and Alzheimer's disease the there are
actually pyramidal neurons in the
hippocampus that die so there's fewer of
the pyramidal neurons that are located
in hippocampus and both the perfusion
measures and the activation measures if
you do brain imaging are decreased in
schizophrenia there is an increase in
perfusion measures there's no difference
in the number of pyramidal neurons but
that but there is a height there's a
evidence for an increase in a
homeostatic plasticity measure so that
there's an there's evidence that in
hippocampus there's really an increase
in activity actually the one could think
of psychosis the way I'm depicting it as
almost a little bit of mild epilepsy
epilepsy of course is is a condition
where an epileptic focus could be
located within hippocampus and it could
could cause a whole unregulated just
discharge of activity from the whole
brain that doesn't happen in
schizophrenia although schizophrenia is
associated with epilepsy to some greater
degree still there's an increase of
activity not a decrease now that the
other questions about the other kinds
of of psychiatric conditions I must say
that I can't answer I've never really
looked at or into these other these
other two the hippocampal pathology and
these other diseases thank you doctor
you have another question as you are
talking about these findings is this
just for adults what if any differences
would you expect for a pediatric
population now that's an interesting
question to on Judy Rapoport at ni-mh
has really looked at a childhood onset
of schizophrenia and she's found almost
no differences between childhood onset
schizophrenia and adult schizophrenia no
difference in symptom content no
difference in cognitive dysfunction no
difference in pharmacologic response
there is there's almost no evidence that
we have to date that the pathology and
childhood onset schizophrenia would be
any different than adult so I would you
know I would just hazard a guess that
they're the same but um but say for sure
that it's a gas thank you our next
question are there any similarities in
the depression in schizophrenia and
Huntington's disease at a molecular
level um well at the present you know
there are some genetic studies that show
that there's an overlap in G woth hits
between depression and schizophrenia but
a very low overlap um Huntington's
disease is it has a known molecular
basis and the Huntington gene it has
never been implicated and very strongly
in schizophrenia or in depression so I
would guess that these are two different
these are all different kind of diseases
and we ought to be looking for
pathophysiology in different places in
the brain and perhaps in different kinds
of molecular pathology
great our next question is it possible
that mercury may disturb calcium
potassium channel in the hippocampus I
can't answer that directly I don't know
enough about channels and I don't know
enough about mercury except to know that
mercury is always bad so i would i would
guess it would be a possibility the from
what I know about ions it's very
difficult for ions to get into the brain
so that there would have to think once
the ions get into the brain there they
probably do a lot they can probably do a
lot of damage but they're dated to be
over the brain that would be my guesses
about that great we have another
question have you or do you know if
anyone has seen equivalent changes in
the ca3 area in any animal model um it's
an interesting question there have been
several animal models one of them that
comes most strongly to mind is the 22q11
deletion model where ca3 neuronal
activity is increased in the in the
22q11 animal model of schizophrenia
there's an increase in ca3 neuronal
firing I don't know in that particular
animal I don't know what the neural
pathology is that would support the
increase in activity we're trying to
work with a couple of other animal
models to see whether or not we can
really recreate this exact tissue
pathology and we're kind of on our way
to doing it although I don't we're not
far enough along for me to really talk
about that here great thank you so much
unfortunately we are out of time I want
to thank the audience for their
interesting questions and participation
in today's event and dr. tamanna for her
informative presentation today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
for the next few months you will receive
an email from labyrinth I'm learning you
to win this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues may have missed
today's live event see you next time
goodbye